you know here's what's interesting about
the real estate market today not that
lot but most houses in most cities the
real estate market is hot I mean it's a
hot in most cities some areas it's just
white-hot
I mean prices are going up house sells
real fast now right and you know the
problem with that when things are going
really really good like that it can put
a mask over stupid you can do some
stupid stuff and a hot market will help
you overcome it now that's not the case
in her situation her situation she just
is where she is but I'm talking about if
you got a house you're thinking about
selling you could put that house up for
sale it's all really fast and you you
know you think oh I saved a commission
oh I saved a commission no look at that
I saved the Commission you know a monkey
can sell a house right now here's the
kitchen
that's the bathroom a monkey can sell a
house right now there's some monkeys out
there the real estate licenses right now
there's a few of them they're people
that sold one house to house they never
got they only get in the business when
it's easy to do it's easy to do right
now here's the problem though you're
dealing with a two hundred thousand
three hundred thousand dollar
transaction you know if you make a five
percent mistake on two hundred thousand
dollars that's ten thousand dollars a
monkey could make that mistake
I mean idiot any idiot can sell a house
right now an idiot can make that mistake
you could sell it yourself and you could
be that idiot that made your mistake if
you make a mistake in the transaction
that's only five percent that's a very
slight mistake that's ten thousand
dollars put $10,000 in the middle your
kitchen table and sit there and look at
it a minute go look at that people
always ask Dave why do you endorse
Realtors won't you save the Commission
because you don't save the Commission
doob
here's what the actual data tells us
I've been the real estate business since
I was 18 years old here's what the data
tells us number one if you put a for
sale sign in the yard yourself that's
what we call that in the business or for
sale by owner a Fizbo FSBO you think
you're going to save the 6% Commission
but guess what
Johnny buyer comes up and instead of
going to the house next door that's
listed with a real estate agent he comes
to your house you know why Johnny buyer
came to your house cause of your crappy
little sign he thought he was going to
get the house cheaper since you are
saving the Commission you put that
crappy little sign out there because you
thought you were going to save the
Commission's you know you both can't
save the same Commission and what ends
up happening is you negotiate away part
of the commission or a real estate agent
comes up knocks on your door and says
hey I have a buyer would you pay me the
sellers portion or the buyers portion of
the Commission 3% of the six and you say
sure and you think you made the three
back not on average you haven't
absolutely no representation and you
don't know what they'll flip you're
doing but you sold the house because
it's it's a hot market out there in any
idiot or monkey can sell a house but you
made a five percent error seven percent
error cost you ten grand cost you 20
grand this is what the data tells us
that tells us that if you list a home
with a high-quality real estate agent
not an idiot not a monkey not somebody
that just got in the business because
anybody can sell a house but somebody
that knows what they're doing when you
list a house with a high quality real
estate agent the house sells for more
than enough to cover the Commission more
than the Fizbo would sell for that's the
data in other words the representation
that you get and the commission that you
pay is free because the house will sell
for that much more in a super high
quality agent like one of our endorsed
local providers that we vet out and
these are people who sell 50 houses a
year 100 houses a year $300 a year
whatever these aren't these are not
idiots these are not monkeys these are
the best of the best this is cream of
the crop they're gonna get even more for
the house because they know how to help
you get it on the market right
and guess what it's gonna sell really
fast because they know exactly what
they're doing oh and in the negotiation
you're not going to negotiate away some
little three words in the contract that
costs you three thousand bucks because
you didn't know what it meant there's a
reason that you pay for expertise the
reason you don't remove your own kidney
at least most of you because you use a
professional to do it because when you
remove your own kidney you're doing all
kinds of damage there's a reason you
don't you know do your own whatever
right you hire a professional right and
that's what you're doing the real estate
business that's why I am very proud to
continue to say real estate agents that
really know their stuff are worth every
dollar that you pay them they make you
that much more sells faster has a higher
likelihood of selling period sells for
more and you don't make stupid mistakes
negotiating the closing costs and the
nuances of the deal because you don't
know what the flip you're doing don't be
an idiot and or monkey and don't hire an
idiot or a monkey get a professional see
that's why we have these endorse local
providers ee LPS for real estate check
that at Dave Ramsey comm if you're
thinking about buying a house or selling
a house I really believe it's the right
thing to do I really really believe it
yes I do
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh